tonight as the white sox look to make it
six in a row they'll be in milwaukee
once again to take on the milwaukee
brewers the two top guns
one on each staff brewers and socks game
number two from miller park so the
brewers have two on nobody out for
yelich
three two coming
fastball strike three pinpoint outside
corner one gone big strikeout he went to
the fastball he was able to locate that
he threw one up and in the pitch before
this time he threaded the needle on the
outside corner
on the ground third base side moncada
madrigal double play nicely done that
was brilliant hair trigger stuff
woodruff keeps pouring in the strikes
on these white sock hitters that one's
in there a call strike three and
carnacion is gone
that's the second strikeout for woodruff
he got him woodruff strikes out mazara
back-to-back case
his third strikeout out number two of
the second inning that pulled the string
on it
89 miles an hour jimenez takes a lead at
first would your deals ground ball right
to second base hiro will make the play
and woodruff with two clean innings as
far
here's robert now back to the top of the
order
that ball is ripped into center field
a base hit magical on his way to third
garcia's throw comes in and it is in
time the rookie is cut down at third
base
boy javi garcia with a perfect strike
right on the bag yep he couldn't walk it
in there any better i think that we got
magical has an issue up there with his
arm
but a perfect throw by garcia he charged
the baseball first of all you get robert
on an o2 pitch and this time able to
center on the
fastball magical gets to second just as
garcia gets the baseball in a perfect
peg the third he's got that
brace on the wrist and looks like he has
injured that again he did not look
comfortable coming off the field
immediately calling for help and the
wins
so the middle infield with the white sox
continues with their injury struggles
what a beautiful throw from avi garcia
i'm going to jam that back arm the hand
into the dirt and he's hurt
and i mean he came up and he came up
instantly and i don't know if he jammed
his hand
so here is y'all monkana
there he goes pitch inside and he is
safe another stolen base for robert in
the series three in the last two days
and although it was fairly accurate it
wasn't awfully quick for nervias
we talk about acceleration
and he's got it in abundance i mean he's
just off to the races he looks back see
if there's a play there was
and of course when you go in like that
you have to hook the bag and he was able
to do it
and he hits a bullet oh what a play by
hira recovers throw to first in time wow
that's big league right there
casting here with an absolute gem
out in the grass on the ship to take
care of moncada good to see he's got the
arm strength to be able to get up it's a
long throw out there in a short right
and able to get monkata
that beauty that saves a run great play
outstanding because you know robert was
going to be able to score on that if it
gets to the outfield
infield in here's ben gamel
gamble sends one to right field that is
way back and there it goes
ben gavel with a two-run blast
the brewers have the lead in the fifth
inning as gamble continues his hitting
ways two pretty good swings right there
first by morrison now gamble taking one
out of here second homer of the year uh
no doubter deep into the bleachers in
right field
so here's eloy jimenez
eloy cracks this ball
deep center field bring him
home we are tied at two
that center field power is
mammoth the reason he got a slider first
pitch was because he hit a 96 mile an
hour high fastball the last time up and
that's exactly why a careless slider
turned into a tie game
got to be a fastball here 1-0
jose rips it to left field and gives the
sox the lead
3-2 socks
can't afford a wild pitch got to throw
him heat 3-2
it's a good thing that mendic was on
third base because that ball was hit
hard it was a one hopper to yelich and i
don't think mendix scores on this
i mean fastball jose cranked it and the
wild pitch set up the go ahead run jose
abreu has become one of the really good
clutch hitters in all of baseball
you call them a against ben gamble who
homered in the fifth
on the ground to first jose's got it
sucks win again in milwaukee how about
that first six-game road winning streak
since
2015.
that's pretty impressive